welcome back the kirk kirkorian school
of medicine at unlv is in the middle of
construction
crews broke ground last fall and expect
to complete the new medical school
by 2022. our bianca holman is live in
the medical district explaining
what this means for health care here in
our valley bianca
well this building is made of steel and
while yet firm and sturdy
it's still flexible to grow with the
ever-changing advances in the medical
field
once this building is complete the unlv
school of medicine will be able to teach
120 future doctors the five-story
building includes the most
tech savvy environments the first two
floors with clinical spaces and labs for
simulation and anatomy
classrooms and a digital library and
administration's office are on the top
three floors
the 150 million dollar project is
important because the school recently
received its final accreditation
maureen shaffer president and ceo of
nevada health and bioscience corporation
says
part of that approval was having a
dedicated medical building
today in southern nevada we are 3 000
doctors short
on average to meet the national average
that this community needs
to service our citizens to receive
average medical care
and i say average in terms of access not
quality
so by building up medical education
building like this
for our new unlv school of medicine it
enables
us the opportunity to grow future
doctors
who will service this community for the
next 50 years
this huge development is on nine acres
in the midst of the medical district and
it's
a great note that all the contractors on
this side are local and they've been
putting in more than 100
000 hours so far now we learned that the
topping off ceremony will happen
this friday reporting from charleston
and rancho bianca holman
8 news now